the Kentucky Derby is rich in tradition
and beauty
it's the longest-running sporting event
in the US and it's considered the most
exciting two minutes in sports
last year American Pharoah made history
by winning the Derby then the Preakness
and the Belmont the elusive Triple Crown
after his amazing career on the track
Pharaoh's starting his second career as
a stallion
but the Derby spotlight this year isn't
on a P it's on the up-and-coming sire
Uncle Mo he's up against America's top
stallion tap it if you want to breed
your mare with him it will cost you
$300,000
both Taffet and Uncle Mo will have three
of their offspring running for the roses
this will be the first time in history
two stallions will have three horses
each in the derby uncle Mose first
offspring propelled him to third when it
comes to sire earnings this year and
it's given him a leg up on tappet with
the favorite Nyquist on Derby Day Moe's
career on the track was exceptional as a
two-year-old but as a three-year-old he
got sick he was scratched from the 2011
Derby then retired to the bar stallion
then he was a racehorse but he's going
to be which is really really cool uncle
Mose co-owner microp old cheered with 40
members of his friends and family as
they watched homebred horse outwork one
of Uncle Mo's sons win the Wood Memorial
victory guaranteed outwork and the third
mow baby a spot in the Derby grooving
uncle Mose progeny are a force to fear I
think it's just in the short time he's
been a sire he's already proved that
he'll be one of the greatest sighs of
all time this is first crop I mean it's
pretty special
dude when he and Mitch 220,000 old
bought uncle mo in 2009 for $220,000 and
before he was retired mo won over 1.6
million dollars on the track now as the
mo baby's prepared a run for the roses
the pole is readying to cash in on their
success uncle mo is visited by 150 to
200 mayors each year with resolve
springs recent success visits could rise
to $150,000 each that's double the
$75,000 he demands now that means he
could bring in 20 million dollars next
breeding season at his valuation is now
100 million dollars
you